okay so now you can imagine what's
happened is he was on pleasure island
and everything went to hell
fundamentally and so
he jumped into the water to escape from
that and that's equivalent to plunging
into chaos and so chaos was
an escape from pathological tyranny
and now he's tried to go home so this is
the
psyche
in its search for maturation runs into
an obstacle which is the tyrannical
element of the great father that it
cannot cope with and it trots home runs
home it's a defeat typical part of a
hero story is the initial defeat of the
hero when he
encounters usually either the terrible
great father or the terrible great
mother
so and so this is a retrogressive
jung would call this retrogressive
restoration of the persona
so it's sort of like maybe you're a
well-adapted adolescent and you live at
home and you're a happy adolescent and
everything's good at home and then you
go out to try to be an adult and you
fail and then when you come back home
you try to act like a happy adolescent
again but you're not what you are in
fact is an unhappy adult and if you move
back to the happy adolescent mode of
being then it's it's false and
pathological you can't go home again
another typical motif in literature
now the cricket
i can't tell you everything about this
story
i can tell you a couple of strange
things about it one is that the cricket
is jiminy cricket right and the initials
of jiminy cricket are jc and jiminy
cricket was a common southern american
um
mild form of
cursing it's the equivalent of jesus
christ and so you might think and of
course
the cricket is pinocchio's conscience
and
well so then you might ask yourself why
in the world would a
pejorative mildly pejorative term for
jesus christ be applied to a cricket
who's guiding a puppet into the water to
rescue his father from a whale why would
any of that happen
and the answer to that is you know why
but you can't say why you can't say
why you know or what it is that you know
but the mere fact that it makes sense
and it does is an indication from a
union perspective that you're operating
at an archetypal level you understand
this
and so i could say here's an example of
why the cricket is a bug
well things bug you
right we say that things bug me well you
should do something about
the things that bug you
because
that's your conscience calling to you
it's it's destiny in some sense
manifesting itself as an unconscious
impulse that really bugs me means
if you can you should do something about
it because you think about it man
there's a lot of things out there that
might bug you but lots of them don't but
some of them do
well why do those bug you and not the
other things
well
that's a complicated question but one
potential answer to it is that
there's part of your psyche that's
oriented towards further development
jung would call that the self and that's
like the totality of everything that you
could be
and it's it's it's it's a it's a strange
sort of entity in some sense because
it's partly potential and it's potential
that expands across time but the way
that your potential totality calls to
you in the present
is by placing things in front of you
that are your problem
and they announce themselves as your
problem and they do that by bothering
you
so then if you pick up the task of
fixing the things that bothers you then
you find the pathway to further
expansion of your personality
so and that's what's happening with
pinocchio now one of the things that's
really interesting about the pinocchio
movie that makes it incredibly
sophisticated is that despite the fact
that the cricket is a avatar of christ
so to speak
the cricket has things to learn just
like pinocchio
and so that's very cool because it's so
cool it's so sophisticated because it
means that you do have a conscience that
guides you
but until you establish a dialogue with
it
both you and the conscience are immature
you have to establish a conscious
dialogue with it and then interact
together in a manner that propels your
development across time and that'll stop
you from being a marionette of forces
that would make you a braying donkey who
does nothing but slave away in salt
mines
so
okay so pinocchio goes home that doesn't
work and that's where we're gonna start
here
i mean obviously this is starting to
bother you as this year you buy into it
to begin with
and and you're enthusiastic about it to
begin with and you attribute that to
well the mechanics of the initial uh
education let's say
um it's it's a it's a group phenomena it
capitalizes on empathy it and it sounds
benevolent certainly
um in fact it's it's the very essence of
benevolence in some sense so it's it's
it's a it's going to be seductive
regardless of whether or not it's
correct but you you become uncomfortable
with it well the first thing you're
uncomfortable with is that you were
implicitly
asked
to
produce a falsehood in relationship to
your own identity which was yeah when
you were asked the question about what
you liked about being white and you said
that what you said wasn't
right exactly or wasn't correct wasn't
true it was something that you whipped
up on the spot because of the nature of
the demand of the situation and you
remember that so obviously that's
significant i think i was just meeting
what i thought was an absurdity with an
absurdity
you know like i i felt the question was
a little bit absurd it's sort of like a
hot the premise
right the premises what do you call it
like how long have you been beating your
wife kind of question
you know so the premise of whiteness
is
you're supposed you have to accept the
premise in order to answer the question
i i really have never been comfortable
with the premise period because i don't
think that it
you know right it takes a lot of
presence it takes a lot of presence of
mind
when you're asked a question to question
the question
especially when you're the student and
it's the teacher that's so to speak it's
the authority figure that's posing the
question because you immediately have to
rebel and you have to do it in an
extremely sophisticated way
yeah and you know this could get back to
the school and i might not have passed
the class and you know i'm i'm white so
that would have been problematic and why
are you why and that would might have
had job repercussions or you know
promotions or whatever you know you just
you realize that to question this
question mandatory yeah and to question
the question in these circumstances is
you know the the risk of that is so much
greater than the
the triumph of of dismantling the
question that you're just not you're
never gonna
and you may see you may even fail at
dismantling the way like your little
your little rebellion may lead nowhere
and you may be wrong
you know which is the hesitation that
anyone would have with an objection just
that you might be wrong and so of course
you're just going to fall on that side
of the equation i mean that's what i did
some people don't but that would you
know no most people do
yeah and no wonder
right it's hard not like you you
outlined a bunch of reasons why it's
difficult to you know come up with
exactly the right response at that
second it's not like it's a question
you're prepared for
right right and you know i think i think
the students do it all the time you know
because there's tremendous social cost
to challenging any of the
assumptions of our anti-racist
programming or the the manner in which
it's delivered what are the costs for
the students um
social you know social appropriation
um
uh
you could have you know teachers write
recommendations for them if they get a
reputation that there's a fear that it
could affect
their
applications um
students have have come to me with
you know concerns and and examples of
papers that they wrote say you know on
taking a position
that went against the orthodoxy and
they've you know suffered a great hit
from it and i've i've asked him like are
you sure
it just wasn't a good paper you know are
you sure and then like no i actually
cited this this and this and i just took
it you know and so i think
um
i think they're real i think that
they're real and there's actually been
you know stories that i've that they've
brought to me that are you know
someone defends capitalism or something
and then they have a big talking to
after class or something like that which
is just
well yes i mean how could you possibly
defend capitalism while you're going to
a 55 000 a year private school
right right um i mean
what's the probability that your parents
are capitalists a hundred percent very
high very young so basically you're
you're being you're being set to task
because you
have the goal to defend
the very attribute of your parents that
enabled you to go to the school in the
first place and that of course enabled
the school
right and it's so it's such an ironic
thing that both the administration and
most faculty have such contempt
for
the very thing that makes them have a
job
you should be talking about ideas based
on what make ideas
sound or unsound not not the person
who's saying them
so
oh i was seeing situations where um you
know white students would make a claim
and then that claim was discounted by
someone else because of their privilege
right they're making of course the white
supremacists assumption that there are
such things as ideas and that they can
be rank in terms of quality and that the
purpose of discursive speech is
precisely to do such things and
etc etc yeah and so the whole
solipsistic nature of it i was like this
is
you can't even have a conversation this
is not this is not a way to have a
functioning
you're not you're not preparing people
to function in a in a
truly
diverging world of ideas it's not well
it's it's worse in some sense is that
the claim fundamental claim is that
there's no such thing as a conversation
there's just different discourses of
power
there's no conversation conversation
assumes ideas and the free flow of ideas
and the an irrational individual actor
and the capacity for logos and and the
individual as the central unit and and
so on and so forth
people who hold the critical race
position let's say
don't
uh
it's not that they avoid
confrontational conversations they don't
believe that there's such a thing as a
conversation it's not part of the system
so
it's a fundamental dispute
yeah no that's true i mean and i i
and then the little things like i
remember talking to a colleague
about a nuke about a new hire and then
and and she said um i said well
well what's he like
this new guy and she said well he's like
you
he's like me well
what do you mean by that and she was
like oh he's white
i was like okay
all right you know this is not a person
that's a total stranger either and i
kind of walked away and like really
so okay and you know i also i also hear
the objection to my to my objection
which is you know see how it feels white
man see how it feels to be treated as
your race that is it's it's a
you know she might have been trying to
teach me a lesson in some sense like
now you know how it feels
but that's not
you know okay that's that's a point that
you're making
but that's not that's not a healthy
thing and
that's not that's not good because it
doesn't actually
reduce the sum total of misery in the
world yeah i mean yeah
um
all right so you're starting to get
feel disquiet and you actually make this
known
yes and i i make it known in 2019
i make it known in in 2020 i talk to the
assistant head i talk to the head of
school
you're married
i i'm recently married i was i've been
married over a year just over a year do
you do you have any children no children
no children but you are married and okay
so i'm just wondering what you have
resting on your jaw exactly yeah yeah
and i i didn't you know i'm i have to
say that
you know
not having kids is is is a huge part of
why i feel like this is happening
that i've been able to to stick my neck
out
um
and
you know i'm not not um
i don't judge anyone for for for
balancing their duty to the truth and
their duty to their family in whatever
way that works for them because both of
them are important
or to put things at risk
you know that's that's a personal choice
and that's
i can can't speak to any of that but i
think it definitely
not having
mouths to feed and and you know having
having some savings from my previous job
and and things um
being smart with my money and not
spending it um unwisely as i have as i
had done
a decade and a half ago but um
i think that that helped me
to do what i'm doing
all right so how are you being treated
by the administrative officials to whom
you're
registering your objection are you doing
that in writing are you doing that in
person you know mostly in person and you
know i'm not writing anything official
i'm i'm in the grumbling in my beard
phase i guess i'm in the griping phase
uh where i would go and i would say you
know this is wrong like why can't we
teach
you know a broad range of viewpoints why
do we always have to teach this
ritualistic thing that's just a litany
of you know
basically far left ideas and you know
some of some some of the administration
were
very sympathetic like even overly so
like i remember talking to
the assistant had he pulled down a copy
of jonathan hate off the off the
bookshelf and was like i'd love to teach
this in my class when i i really want to
make this happen i want to teach you
know so you know more more than i was
sort of or maybe just modeling it or
humoring me or something but he had the
book he had the book that's right and he
knew the book and he knew he knew where
it was on his show
i know so like
but you know then in public you know or
in public in the in front of the
community you're not saying nothing
about it right so i think there's a
tremendous amount of preference
falsification
still going on there you know well you
outlined why i mean yeah you lost your
job
yeah so you know
these are high stakes games and right
you make a mistake and and a mistake
you you veer outside the the realm of
acceptable behavior let's say
and what happens
well
you get disproportionately punished for
it and there's a moral element to it too
which is well
there's no bloody way someone like you
should be teaching so not only did we
fire you but we're right to do so
yeah so and you know that's very hard
thing to withstand which is something i
also want to talk to you about i mean
you know
confident though you may be
or anyone maybe when your institution
sheds you
and surrounds that with accusations
about the nature of your character if
you're not a complete psychopath it
tends to strike you to your heart
because there's always the possibility
that you're wrong right right but i i
really i really knew i wasn't because
you know coming out there was this
meeting and i referred to it in in the
article or my essay the self-care
through an anti-bias lens meeting
which is what kicked off the whole
past two months for me
it was a
it was a meeting where
students were ostensibly going to learn
how to take care of themselves during
the pandemic
how to
manage their emotions
how to
take deep breaths and cope with things
and in that meeting you know after some
some mind relaxing exercises like
meditation and
and stuff they put up the white
supremacy you know
aspects of white supremacy culture slide
and that's different than the pyramid or
this is different than the pyramid and
this is you know this is elements of
white supremacy right right it's
actually um you know they there's
different forms of it
but essentially you know it's
it's fairly common in this in this thing
as you know and um
yes so here's some
professional and transactional
relationships versus relationships based
on trust care and shared commitments
protecting power versus sharing power
culture of overworking versus culture of
self-care and community care competition
and struggle for limited resources
versus collaboration and working to
share resources that's all white
dominant culture so
yes yes and so some of the things that
were on this particular slide
were objectivity
individualism
um either or thinking
right right and uh i know that one
there was um you know the
the thing that wrangled me the most was
right to comfort
because
you know how how are you giving a
self-care
workshop where
the 200 kids that are in there in this
racially segregated workshop
are
challenged that they might not you know
that having imagining that you have a
right to comfort is associated with a
you know genocidal evil kenneth jones
and timo oaken dismantling racism
workbook 2001. god only knows what that
is but it's everywhere the
characteristics of white supremacy
culture perfectionism which is an
element of conscientiousness which is a
fundamental trait sense of urgency
defensiveness quantity over quality
worship of the written word paternalism
either or thinking notice this is all
written in words by the way power
hoarding fear of open conflict
individualism which seems to be run
somewhat counter to the fear of open
conflict progress is bigger and more
objectivity right to comfort yeah it's
uh it's quite the grab bag of
conceptually unrelated items
it's incoherent at every possible level
of analysis as well as being
it's it's
impossible to parody
yeah
yeah and i i saw it and i you know i had
been thinking for a couple months prior
to this because there had been some
meetings that really upset me
and i was thinking well
and my head of school had actually said
that if i was in an appropriate forum
i should feel free to ask questions
by this point in the meeting i think
maybe 30 minutes in before this popped
up other faculty had been saying things
in the chat area of the zoo meeting
so you know is that anonymous is that
anonymous in the zoo no it's it's they
were so they were under their own names
under their own names yeah um
and so i thought well why you know
when the when the facilitator mentioned
that if you looked at this slide i think
she said i think she said you know you
might have some white feelings
um
and i said i just kind of blurted out i
didn't i didn't blurt it out angrily i
didn't
i don't think i was too upset of course
you know i
i don't know how it was perceived of
course but
i said well what do you mean but what is
a white feeling what is the white
feeling
and i you know what came back was
i think she said something that
defensiveness was a white feeling i said
well these
feelings can belong to people of any
race and you know i think that it's
i i don't know whether it's
i don't understand why it's being
attributed to a particular
the white people
um
and you know i had
that kind of opened
the gates a little bit and kind of
broke the ice i think because in the
chat other kids started to ask questions
there was a debate about whether i
should be allowed to ask the question
um
there was which question do you mean the
question about the white feeling
question
i see
there were also some
there was a lot of capitalism bashing in
the chat and i said you know i believe
capitalism is anti-racist since it's
done more to to lift
people of all races out of poverty um
than any any alternative
um
and you know i wasn't monopolizing the
chat i was dropping in little things and
there was a lot of activity in the chat
and then um
the the the facilitator actually went
with me and she she explained stuff you
know
her perspective on it and i thanked her
and you know she moved on some more and
um
i think i i asked another question but i
really as as she said later in a meeting
about the meeting in front of the whole
faculty she
felt that i you know i was asking out of
curiosity didn't i wasn't you know on a
rant or saying it you know to to be
antagonistic
i think some of the some of my faculty
members felt that i was but the
facilitator herself didn't feel that way
so and she was the one i was talking to
so i think that definitely counts that's
quite remarkable i would say because
it's very difficult in a group like that
when
you know the implicit ethos
to be able to say something that's
questioning without
having anger build up as a motivation
right because you need something to
break through your resistance
yeah so yeah to be able to say it
without upsetting the
the uh
yeah i mean i was passionate but i
wasn't i don't think i was like enraged
or anything like that um
it's you know i was trying to modulate
what i was really upset i was that was
the either or thing because i was like
well if either or
thinking is a
is a characteristic of white supremacy
well then ibram kennedy's got to be the
whitest person in public life because
his entire philosophy is so
manichaean
i mean
anyway so but i didn't say that of
course because that would have been
inflammatory but um
what i really wanted to do i've been
thinking about an opportunity because i
wanted to model for the students that
you could ask questions that someone who
who was a teacher or someone who was an
authority figure could ask a question
and it was okay
and and did and how did the students
react to it was it was phenomenal i mean
i was really gratified and that they
confirmed that my
it confirmed that i was doing the right
thing because when things came out in
the chat they started to ask a broader
range of questions i received the
transcript later and
you know it was like night and day kids
were asking questions like well i don't
feel like i'm ignorant just because i'm
white
or you know i don't like to be reduced
to my race and then faculty joined in so
several faculty members also
started to ask questions
um you know and i i don't think the
point was that they people they if
people even necessarily wanted their
questions answered
in the forum they just wanted to ask
them
i
you don't know what your question is
until you ask exactly like
this this that's why i think intent is
so
it's kind of a silly thing because you
never really it's only an ex post facto
explanation if you're called on it i
think like a true question there may be
no intent
like it just bubbles out of you if
you're if you're truly in a in a
conversation i'm not thinking about
okay i'm not it's not like i'm plucking
this little thing out of the inside of
my head and like well i intend this to
be you know that's not communication
that's not if it's a genuine
conversation no you don't have time for
that in a genuine conversation no yeah
of course not and so you know but
i was really gratified i was on a
natural high from the experience
why
well because i felt that i had you know
i had done something
good like it was just self-evidently
good to me like it just when i reflected
on it this is a positive thing
now
one of the my colleagues got very upset
with me with my influence on this and
um because at one point i did say
you know why
you know
i don't identify as white must i
internalize society's delusions about me
um which is you know like
it's kind of like the neutron bomb to
this entire belief system but i i was on
i was on a you know i felt like it was
something i wanted to put out there
so the kids could see it
and you know understand you know that
maybe this is a point of view you know
i'm not saying i'm right i'm i'm asking
a question
um
and you know the the feeling was that
this was you know anti-racism
some defense
yeah like i could do they're not morally
obligated to accept these
characterizations right which is kind of
the whole point of anti-racism is that
you're not obligated to
accept arbitrary racial categories that
are unrelated to the task at hand
yeah
it should be
um
but uh you know then a colleague got
upset with me and said kind of got on
his high horse and and said uh you know
i can't believe that
i may be mis
you know paraphrasing here and if i am
sorry
but he said i believe you know i can't
believe that a member of our you know
our one of my colleagues doesn't
understand that we are white
that we are white since birth i am white
since birth that this has carries with
it implicit biases that are unavoidable
and we must affirm that
you know and and that's who that's who
we are and that's who i am and i just it
kind of interrupted him because i felt
like he was kind of
making me look
i know he's being kind of kind of a jerk
so i interrupted him and said
i'm sorry you're stereotyping yourself i
think it's sad
uh
and
you know that kind of was a very awkward
moment because it was in front of
students
and he said you know he expressed his
dismay um
and i remained silent and then after the
meeting i said i apologized to him i
said you know that was unprofessional
was it
well you know i i unders i felt it i
felt that there might have been a better
way that i could do it
maybe wait till he finished and then
asked you know to respond
i i i'm
i'm also suspicious of my own
you know because i i have been somewhat
oppositional i'm not exactly like a mr
gohan and get along guy
with this stuff that i don't always have
the best reality check on my own
behavior
and so i'm you know i i was just
saying well okay if i if i did
cause offense then you know i i feel
like it's okay to apologize and there
probably was a better way for me to do
this and so i did apologize and you know
and thought about it he know nothing
against that nothing wrong with that and
then he accepted
and you know i figured that was that was
it and there was a lot of processing
after the meeting i think
that went on for hours afterwards my
phone died it was on my phone and so
when i went home
um i logged back into the meeting and
people were still there talking so i
talked to them
but i underestimated the effect of this
because apparently um some of my
some of my comments you know were leaked
or made or transmitted to other people
that weren't in the meetings people that
were in the the bipark meeting
you know
particularly my
mice
is
a black and indigenous people of color
so they were having their separate
meeting of faculty and students where
they received different content
and why was it separate
curiosity
the rationale as i could as i can
understand it is so that
the groups that have been marginalized
won't be exposed to you know they'll
have their own thing so that they're not
exposed to the
i think the incense and possible
insensitivity of the
[Music]
oppressors
that's the best i can understand the
rationale
um
but it wound up happening anyway because
i suppose it would be rude of me to
point out that that's somewhat
paternalistic
you know just as a yeah you know
observation that's a good one um yeah i
mean yeah totally well i guess that is a
characteristic of white supremacy
culture though paternalism
yeah so and i guess it's
as long as it's in a good cause then i
guess it's forgivable
yeah okay so that was how long ago that
meeting
that was february 24th
oh yes okay so things are starting to
yeah this year and that was referred to
after the fact as the events of
wednesday like they couldn't even really
it was sort of like 9 11
they couldn't actually they had to come
up with a euphemism for it i guess
so the events of wednesday and so they
had meetings about the events
well the office of community engagement
coupled with the dean of student life
and there
there are
dean
level positions
that
exerted a lot of effort and energy
because i did not make their lives easy
um
to
to address the things that were said and
raised in the meeting not just by me but
by
you know lots of different people
and students students you know spoke up
as well
and faculty and so
um
what i found it so interesting because
the day after the meeting
there was an email that was released
that said healing resources you know
healing resources
that will help
you
come to terms with what happened and the
first healing resource
on the list was a cnn interview with a
poet named damon young
um and um
damon young uh you know
in this interview said things like
you know we
we need to get rid of all of capitalism
we will have to do a carpet bombing not
a carpet cleansing of society and it was
incredibly radical statements that
were i would imagine would be
frightening to to many people and that
was listed as a healing resource as well
as well as long as the carpet bombing
only targets the malevolent people
well yeah i guess and then things there
was a robin d'angelo article that said
you know what white people need to be
made or kept uncomfortable
how can we become more uncomfortable
also
you know really kind of i would just say
racist characterizations of white people
in these links
things like you know white people have
never had to be guests in this country
and
uh like the irish for example
they weren't really white to begin with
though so
yeah yeah um
and so
i found this very ironic and then i had
a series i had two meetings i had a
meeting with my
head of high school and the assistant
head
and i had a meeting with the head of the
whole school
and then you know i
the head of the meeting with the
head of high school they called you in
at that point yeah i mean what's
happening around you is this is growing
this is this well yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of agitation there's
meetings about meetings there's student
diversity council meetings
um there are
um
there's just a lot of agitation in the
community i would say uh and
and meetings about meetings so some of
the things that would happen would be in
the week in
the end as the week continued there was
a faculty meeting about it
um
i had some advisory circles circle
practice
was taken away because they felt that it
would be the students would be upset if
i was a part of it
so the
investigation
is what
um well it was it's a it's a practice
that we've started this year
where
activities
um
where you you put up a slide and you
talk about an issue and then everyone
has to go around and speak one by one
about a question and then you kind of do
it around twice
and then you know this is to sort of
manage discussion
um
and i've done so you're not you're
persona non grata at this now because
yeah
your toxic influence on the students
right or right and so you know
i got an email saying you know under
current circumstances following
yesterday's meeting and you're ruled and
what transpired
you you know i've asked you to recuse
yourself
um
then you know
there were subsequent meetings there was
a faculty meeting
i think at that faculty meeting
a colleague said well this is this could
be terrible this could undo everything
we've ever taught them
which i thought to myself please please
i hope so
um but uh
the
uh
and there was how are you how are you
reacting to all this well i'm on a
natural high i mean i i know that i feel
like this is something that i finally
done
to
to open up something like some daylight
and i
all of this churn is going on around me
but i'm going about my day i'm teaching
my classes
i'm
you know i i did feel the need to
address my classes so i said at the
beginning you know i am an anti-racist
um you know i want you to feel safe and
then i would just sort of teach the
class and then i was told not to address
it with the class with anyone in the
classes with regard to teachers and
students in private and public
institutions high schools junior highs
elementary schools
in your state and across your country
what
what do you see this
if anything what does this indicate
well i have hopes you know i i feel that
if if
students can if i if if the type of
you know willingness to ask a question
it in response to some of these
you know what i consider to be
indoctrination frankly at other schools
and you think that's happening in other
schools yeah i mean i it's no question
because of the the calls that i've
received in the conversations i've had
with people all over
pennsylvania virginia maryland new
jersey you know their their parents are
very concerned with their children
they've seen it because of the pandemic
through their through the zoom zoom
classes
they've witnessed what's being taught to
their kids
and they're very very concerned and they
have specific receipts to back it up and
you know they're sending me
curriculum
um so
you know i i this is not simply a
a rarefied
independent school problem this is
happening at you know school boards and
districts all over the country
um
a lot of it spurred by the you know the
george floyd
it's killing
and the reaction to it um i believe it
was taken as an opportunity to you know
redress
um
that with uh misguided
yeah an opportunity for what it's like
i'm trying to figure out i keep trying
to figure out because i've been
concerned about this for a long time
and uh
i still can't get to the bottom of it
it's like i don't understand exactly i
know there's a resentment element to it
but i can't understand exactly what's
driving this and and why it's
despite the fact that it's clearly the
view of a very small minority of people
perhaps five percent that's what the
survey seemed to indicate i cannot
understand why it's making the headway
that it's making at the rate that it's
making
and what it's really aiming at
what do you think about that
like what's your sense because obviously
it's bothering you
yeah i think i have a sense
why and maybe it's a theory it's not
just my theory but it's i've seen it in
other places or hinted at other places
i think when you sort of
you know over the past
few decades you have a gradual
sort of leaching from the soil of
society of sort of a moral sense a moral
tradition moral
grounding in
you know long long religious traditions
essentially when they depart from the
public sphere it leaves a kind of vacuum
and you know
wokeness is is a way to
sort of sort of paint by numbers moral
righteousness and it gives people the
sense that they're good people i think
people have an almost
you know i don't know whether it's
evolutionarily based but they have a
need to have a moral
character and sense of themselves and if
and if something comes along which is
going to offer that and give you that
thing well then
there's a there's a tremendous hunger
for it so people will adopt it quickly
and so you can have
you know a very small
percentage of the population that's
pushing it can have a real powerful
outsized influence do you do you have a
traditional religious belief of any sort
and are you a practicing religious
person
i am i am
it's a really good question i am i was
raised catholic
and i you know was have lapsed
you know i i have a joke that i i use
sometimes you know i'm so lapsed i'm
prolapsed
but uh
basically
uh i i
you know was a functioning agnostic then
atheist
uh and um
but i i don't feel like i really need
a lot of god
but i do need to have something which is
like a conscience like i guess i believe
in a conscience
i believe in some little
mirror of the divine which sort of is is
in me it's not like above me or around
me but it is within me and so it's sort
of like a reflective
thing that i can
and it's sort of reactivated i guess and
as part of this whole experience
so i can
i can take in
the world and the world of reality but i
can reflect it against something which
is not of this world
i don't know how to describe it and then
that's pretty good what comes back i'm
i'm satisfied with that answer you know
like what comes back is something that i
should attend to it's something that is
the it is it is something important and
that is the
you know and and now that i feel like i
have that or an awareness of that
you know it's just like you know ah
you know
okay like i've got thank god it's been
there exactly thank god i want to say
thank god but i don't i don't i don't
know i don't know that there's a god
with a capital g
i just know that there's something which
is
which is not of this world but is in
this world
my point my principal argument in the
book is that uh
absolute freedom of speech is always
going to be better and in fact by
promoting free speech you're doing
something to help those very people that
you are concerned about
so recently the scottish parliament
passed
a
hate crime law
that has its supporters and also its
detractors and
i
be interested in your feeling about that
now you said i believe in this book if
if i remember the statistics correctly
that
there have been 120 000
incidents of police investigated
speech hate crime in
britain in how long since
yeah that's been over the last five
years or so it's it's it's worse than
that the statistic i quote is between
2014 and 2019 there are 120 000 recorded
incidents of non-crime
they call them non-crime hate incidents
and this is something which is now
routine in the uk i mean obviously i'm
going to be talking about the uk and the
u.s and canada is a very is a very
different kettle of fish i'm sure um and
i'm sure a lot of the people who are
watching won't be familiar with with the
problems we have in the uk of course we
don't have constitutional protection for
free speech we don't have a first
amendment uh we don't have anything like
that so we are particularly vulnerable
and at the moment unfortunately in the
uk uh the police who are uh trained by
the college of policing who do issue
very specific guidelines about this and
anyone can check this because if you go
to the government's website on hate
crime and hate speech
they make very clear what they're
talking about what they say is that
there are five protected characteristics
and these fall into race gender
sexuality gender identity and disability
um i think i might misquote that but
there's one missing but anyway there are
five protected characteristics and if
a victim and they do use the word victim
rather than complainant if a victim
perceives that any speech or crime was
motivated by hatred towards any of those
five protected characteristics then it
qualifies as a hate crime if it's
criminal if it's not criminal if it's
just speech or something like that it
qualifies as a non-crime hate incident
police will investigate that they will
record that and although non-crime
incidents don't lead to prosecution they
do go on a criminal reference check that
many people take we call it a disclosure
barring service here so it can affect
your employment prospects uh and is that
without a trial that was recorded
without a trial of course
so you get a quasi-criminal record you
get something flagged up when you
particularly if you're applying for a
teaching job say something like that
where you're working with children it's
very important and you get this thing
flagged up so it does have serious
ramifications but even beyond that we
have hate speech laws which are encoded
into
the public order act which is one
example but the other the main example
is the electronic communications act
2003. in this country and i do quote the
statistic in the book as well we have
roughly uh 3 000 people arrested
a year
um for um offensive things that they
have said online that's that's so in
other words nine people a day roughly
the police in the uk are arresting
and that people in the uk will be
familiar with this because if you see
the twitter accounts of various police
forces various police departments across
the country they often put things out
like
you know make sure you don't say
anything offensive or thoughtless online
or we will be knocking on your door they
say these very kind of
frightening
things there was a uh a recent police um
display outside a supermarket um in the
uk it went viral this image it was them
next to a big digital billboard and the
slogan on the billboard was being
offensive is an offense and this was
flanked by police officers who were
socially distanced but they were there
in their masks which made it seem
slightly more sinister um they got in a
lot of trouble for that because people
were saying well being offensive surely
isn't a crime um but actually the
problem with that is that the police
clearly thought it was a crime and they
you know they were acting on that basis
they'd obviously hadn't just concocted
this billboard out of nothing they'd
really considered what it should say
and more to the point actually they were
right in this country you can uh go to
prison for jokes for offensive remarks
um and people have gone to prison have
been arrested uh routinely for for
causing offense and of course the notion
of offence is incredibly subjective in
fact in fact the the legal stipulation
in the communications act is that you
will have broken the law if the judge
and jury deem that you have
communicated material that is quote
unquote grossly offensive well i don't
know how you define that i i i wouldn't
also who defines it is the real question
as far as i'm concerned i mean i've
looked into this legislation to some
degree and
one of the things that struck me about
it was that
it seems to be purposefully left up to
the hypothetical victim to define
offense which has become
a subjective reality if if
and and you can understand why that
might be to some degree because
how would you define hate and how would
you define offense without especially
the latter without making recourse to
someone's subjective experience
but then of course
well
we'll delve into that in a moment i
should start with the hard question i
suppose which is
well clearly people can say hateful
things and those things can be damaging
psychologically and
physiologically i suppose if people are
stressed enough and the borderline is
very difficult to
identify um why
is it that people shouldn't just assume
that you're a mean loudmouth and that
they shouldn't pay any attention to you
at all because you're concerned about
this
i mean
which is that's the general criticism of
critics of of hate speech let's say and
so why in the world aren't we aren't the
people who are putting this forward just
trying to make the world a nicer place
what's the big problem here
well i think a lot of people do assume
that i'm a mean loudmouth i think they
assume that about most people who who
defend freedom of speech um
but and and i'm sure the latter part of
your question is is absolutely right
insofar as i imagine a lot of the people
who are skeptical about free speech are
in fact trying to make the world a
better place i don't think that's
mutually exclusive i mean
the the the problem here is that
the legislation as it currently stands
here means that for instance if you say
something critical about me and i
perceive that it was motivated by hatred
towards me on the basis of my sexuality
for instance i could phone the police
and that would be recorded uh and would
appear on hate crime statistics in this
in this country because it's all about
perception that word is used about five
or six times within the one passage in
the in the hate crime legislation the
word perception of the victim and again
i say victim not complainant which
suggests a complete disregard for due
process but i suppose we can leave that
aside but the most common the most
common and the most frightening
misconception i have found when it comes
to people defending free speech is that
they are doing so because they want to
have the right to say appalling things
about people uh with no comeback
whatsoever
and they want to go back to some
imaginary good old days you know where
you could just be casually homophobic
and racist and sexist and all the rest
of it and no one would call you out for
that now i don't know anyone who falls
into that category and and most people
who are um you know advocating for free
speech are doing so precisely because
they are aware that in countries where
free speech protections are meager
minorities tend to suffer the most and
in fact there is a a a uh it seems to be
a corollary to me that those who are
genuinely for free speech are also for
equal rights and protecting the
vulnerable in society and this
perception which i really find
unpleasant this perception that if you
are standing up for this
most foundational of principles
of for freedom of speech if you're
standing up for that you can only be
doing so if you have a nefarious motive
i mean what a horribly pessimistic view
of of humanity and and it seems to be
well it seems to be a direct derivation
of the hypothesis for example that
all
western
social organizations
particularly western
are
based on power and are best conceived of
as tyrannical and so
if that's your view why would you not
assume that most use of speech is
essentially an exercise of power
in the service of tyranny
but then why would you assume
uh that the government in control of any
particular uh country isn't part of that
tyranny that you're describing it it
seems odd to me
to be um
mindful of the potential for tyranny but
then to outsource all your individual
liberties to the state it seems
contradictory to me um well i guess the
way that that is uh
um
elided over is
by
allowing the hypothetical individual
victim to define the offense
this is the problem though this is i
mean the problem i've run into and this
is why partly why i appreciated your
book is that increasingly
people are called upon to defend
fundamental assumptions
that were so taken for granted that
virtually no one has an argument
that's fully articulated at hand
when no one questions free speech no one
has to defend it thoroughly as soon as
it's questioned well it becomes an
extraordinarily complicated problem
the same with gender identity when it's
when no one's paying attention to it
it's obvious but as soon as you have to
think it through it becomes a
rat's nest to say the least
when i was in the uk a few years ago i
saw a number of things that i felt were
disturbing
um
seem to have accepted the omnipresence
of cctv cameras to a degree that i found
horrifying frankly i don't like cctv
cameras i don't like
the
the
message they portray which is that
everyone is criminal enough so they
should be surveyed all the time and
someone needs to be watching
i noticed too in london in particular
that
many buildings
had instituted airport level security so
that you had to pass through a metal
detector and have your bags checked etc
while you were moving in and out of
buildings and
it it struck me as quite horrifying
given that as far as i'm concerned
great britain and its legal and
parliamentary traditions are the
epicenter
or at the epicenter of western freedoms
i mean you could make a case for france
i suppose but not a strong one as far as
i'm concerned
yet
this your citizens seem to have accepted
this with
virtually no
problem and now on the heels of that we
have this
multiplication of of hate crime
that's as much a surprise to me as it as
it is to you i mean you won't have seen
all of the cctv cameras believe
apparently they're absolutely everywhere
you can't walk anywhere uh in the uk
without being
potentially monitored um you know i'm
not saying someone's watching you all
the time but but things are being
recorded and digitized um yeah and it's
it's interesting to me because i
remember back in the uh
in the early 2000s when the government
was trying to push through its id card
scheme and broadly speaking the left
were unanimously against it and they
didn't like this idea of living in a
society where there's someone on the
corner saying papers please no one
really wanted that
but we've become very docile and very
accepting of the idea that we need to be
coddled and monitored by the state i
mean i know there's a recent debate
about vaccine passports and people seem
very uh blase about this idea that
that we might have to have uh our id
embedded and encoded onto a card to get
anywhere or to do anything so i think
there's there's something going on there
and it is connected with what you've
brought up in terms of hate crime
legislation we've just become accustomed
i mean you mentioned specifically the
problem in scotland
and and seriously it relates very
closely to what you're saying because
the snp who are the only really party
with any clout in scotland that's the
scottish national party um
and it's never a good idea is it when
you have one political party which
doesn't really have an opposition um
they have a reputation for quite nanny
state-ish policies you know they they
introduced a uh what was it called the
named person scheme it didn't go through
in the end but they wanted to assign
every child born in scotland with a
state guardian you know they effectively
didn't trust uh the parents to raise
their own kids they have other examples
you know minimum pricing on alcohol or a
ban on two for one pizzas because they
don't trust poor people uh not to gain
weight um so all sorts of these sorts of
policies but in this current hate crime
bill which has just sailed through
because there's no opposition uh hamza
youssef the justice secretary has pushed
through he specifically included an
element to this bill which says that
they can criminalize you for things you
say in the privacy of your own home i
mean that to me is i mean that's just a
given i would have never thought that
anyone in this country would not
consider that to be an incredible
invasion of liberty you can make a
strong case for scotland as the
uh ground zero for many of the
developing many of the concepts that
undergird the entire western notion of
freedom and to see that emerging in
scotland is absolutely
stunningly terrifying as far as i'm
concerned you think of mel gibson with a
face covered in woad shouting freedom as
he's executed you know in braveheart you
do think of scotland as being associated
with it but honestly scotland for some
reason and i don't know what it is and
it might be to do that it's effectively
this one party state
it seems to have this incredible sense
and they've really bought into this idea
uh that unless they can police the
thought
the thought and speech of their citizens
then they will just run up run a mock
it's there's another element to that
bill i don't know if you know about this
there's a specific element on the bill
which talks about the public performance
of a play
so they've effectively said
that they will criminalize uh public
performances so say if if it can be
deemed that those performances were
designed to stir up hatred that's the
formulation stir up hatred i'm not quite
sure what that means necessarily but the
when when hamza youssef was questioned
about this in parliament he actually
said well theoretically a neo-nazi or
someone from the far right could get
together with a group of actors and put
on a play to to recruit people to his
cause and as i said at the time you know
i don't know any neo-nazis but they're
not into amateur dramatics that's not
their thing they don't do that they
wouldn't get involved and yet he's got
this idea in his head that that is a
feasible i mean it seems ridiculous but
it's not really because the
ramifications are quite are quite
serious and and it and the way it's just
gone through without any opposition
really really troubles me i mean there
have been modifications i should say in
fairness
in the initial bill in the initial draft
of the bill they had said that you could
be criminalized irrespective of
intention in other words yes that was
terrifying awful and you know if you
wrote a play that then
stimulated someone to join the file
right then you were still responsible
whether you intended it or not now the
problem is you know with theatrical
representation or any kind of artistic
representation is sometimes you want to
represent the worst aspects of humanity
because that's part of drama and
literature and all the rest of it i mean
you would be
there would be no artistic freedom if
that went through so unfortunately
that element of the bill was modified
well and also the attempt to reverse the
idea that intent is important is that's
even that's even more
uh catastrophic it it's always been a
miracle to me that our legal system ever
became psychologically sophisticated
enough so that intent rather than
outcome was what mattered because you
have to be a sophisticated thinker to
see that someone has done damage to
someone else
but and so the damage is real and marked
and and troublesome and costly all of
that painful
but because the intent wasn't there
the
severity of the action is dramatically
mitigated that's a sign of maturity and
sophistication to note that and the fact
that it's built into the legal system is
nothing short of remarkable and then to
remove that and to
make the
the felt consequences the the arbiter of
the reality of the situation is a
dreadful assault on the integrity of the
law as such as far as i can tell
well moreover it's something that
everyone in
intuitively understands we all
understand the difference between murder
and manslaughter you know we all
understand that intent actually does
like you say escalate the
the severity of a crime and and and it's
and it's it's bigger than that isn't it
it's because this like this idea that
intention doesn't matter is actually
built into
so much of this what we call social
justice discourse if you think of
critical race theory uh it's just a
given uh that there are racist
structures and you can be racist without
intending to be racist and i really do
dispute that because i think in order to
be racist intention has to be at the
heart of that otherwise it's incoherent
to me why were you motivated you guys to
do no safe spaces and and what exactly
is it examining
it's examining free speech
which alone i mean first of all uh
everybody involved in it all the
directors the writers the producers were
offend fantastic people
people i i really admire and uh and
adore
and originally
uh
it was with me and then very early on
they said would you like to do with adam
corolla and uh
i i don't know if your uh viewers are
able to perceive this but we uh we
really do adore each other
and um
uh respect each other and
so the thought of doing this with adam
was uh
i was excited and it turned out that i
had every reason to be excited it's a
great chemistry that we have
just to hear adam describe how different
our backgrounds is is worth the price of
admission
which he does most of the time when we
go public
adam why don't you give a brief review
of how different our backgrounds are
well
first our similarities were we're both
over six foot and that's where it ends
uh
dennis is you know a new york he's an
east coast guy i grew up in north
hollywood california then this is
scholar i was put on academic probation
at a junior college
um dennis likes uh
symphonies i like prog rock uh he likes
gefilte fish i like philly cheese steaks
where does it end dennis
uh well what about about the religious
difference
oh yes he's uh a very religious jew i'm
essentially atheist
pagan okay so let me out let me ask you
another question so when i look at
political surveys
i see that
there's a very limited number of people
on the right that you could describe as
extremists and there's a very limited
number of of people on the left who
appear to support the more extremist
leftist propositions
and so i do believe that in some sense
it's more difficult for people on the
left to draw distinctions between
acceptable leftist ideas than it is for
people on the right i mean on the right
you draw the line with claims of racial
superiority on the left there's there's
obviously trouble brewing on the extreme
but defining exactly where it is and
drawing a border around it is seems to
me a relatively complex task and well
you asked me why i got in trouble i mean
i got in trouble because i said well i'm
not sure where to draw the line but that
particular law compelling speech with
its implicit theory of identity that's
gone too far as far as i'm concerned but
you know the fact that that caused so
much trouble i think is indication of
the fact that it's difficult to draw
the line and so well i'm interested in
both your comments about that
well i think you're on to something with
the extreme part of the right
wing party is pretty definable
and i think most reasonable people agree
that the farthest right
you know
jews shooting laser beams into the into
the sky and shooting down satellites or
whatever
crazy stuff comes out of
q and on or sort of far-right stuff
racial things of that nature
um
i think we can all agree that that's
pretty definable
and that most people on the right will
not cross that border
uh and william buckley helped with that
wouldn't you say
i would
but on the left
i feel like there's a much greater sense
of
well we don't agree with aoc but we're
not going to say anything about it or
we're not going to define it or or the
squad so there's a much more you know i
live in california most everyone i work
in hollywood everyone's on the left
their thing is sort of like we don't
like what gavin newsom is doing
but
he's still our guy
and you know we'll go well that's part
that's part of this difficulty
withdrawing borders like i've had
conversations with democrats about the
idea of equity for example which is a
no-go zone as far as i'm concerned
because of its connotations of equality
of outcome but they insist generally
speaking that most of the people who are
using the term equity are really using
it as a proxy for equality of
opportunity